the Goldfinch enthralled readers after
its bullets are winning releases an
acclaimed novel and now it's poised to
have the same effect on film goers as it
arrives in theaters in 2019 wondering
when you can see it who's starring in it
and who's behind the camera here's
everything you need to know
fans of Donna Tartt's work have grown
accustomed to waiting her shortest gap
between novels is the 10-year drought
that spanned her 1992 debut the secret
history and it's follow-up the little
friend so the fact that the Goldfinch
has taken six years to make its way to
the big screen is almost to be expected
I've tried to write faster and I don't
really enjoy it I don't enjoy the
process of doing it I've tried to speed
up but for those who've been eager to
see this story brought to life in
theaters that patience will soon be
rewarded the Goldfinch is scheduled to
arrive on September 13th 2019 a fall
release date for a major motion picture
tends to signal the studio's belief that
the film in question could be a
contender during awards season after
blockbuster season fades in August
audiences tend to be in the mood for
more serious fare and awards voters are
also more likely to remember a movie
that earned acclaim later in the year
whether this confidence pays off after
critics have their say it remains to be
seen but this release date bodes well
for the way studio execs feel about the
Goldfinch when it came time to cast the
goldfinches main character Theo the
minds behind the film knew they would
have to cast someone who could shoulder
every bit of the protagonists intense
harrowing emotional journey and thanks
to a breakout role in a 2017 summer hit
by Edgar Wright's Ansel Elgort ended up
nabbing this huge role the actor had
been making waves for some time
appearing in films like The Fault in Our
Stars in the divergent film series but
according to Variety it was his quiet
yet emotional turn and baby driver that
got him enough attention to book the
role of Theo Elgort and the white Queens
and Irene Bernhard will service the
film's two main stars and the rest of
the cast is appropriately a list perhaps
the biggest name is Oscar and
emmy-winning star Nicole Kidman who has
won critical acclaim for everything from
Moulin Rouge to big little lies you'll
also see Emmy winner Sarah Paulson known
for her work on American Horror Story as
well as recognizable faces like American
horror stories Denis O'Hare old schools
Luke Wilson and stranger things actor
Finn wolfhard with the film rights up
for sale Hollywood started buying in
earnest for the
chance to score tarts first-ever
adaptation and in 2014 a year after the
books release and shortly after won the
Pulitzer Prize a major studio stepped in
to purchase the rights for the Goldfinch
according to Deadline the book which at
this point had spent dozens of weeks on
the New York Times bestseller list was
snapped up by Warner Brothers Studios in
conjunction with Rat Pack entertainment
it made sense at the time for Warner
Brothers to pick up the rights
especially since they had previously
purchased the rights to the secret
history which was never made into a
movie with the secret history still
awaiting development and its
award-winning successor prime for the
screen the Goldfinch became the
immediate focus when it came time to
choose a director for the Goldfinch the
studio settled on John Crowley an Irish
director with a strong background in
theater
Crowley's breakout role came in 2003
with intermission which ones several
filmmaking Awards in Ireland but he hit
even bigger with 2015's Brooklyn an
Academy Award nominee for Best Picture
an enormous Awards season hits Brooklyn
even won the BAFTA for Best British film
considering Crowley has plenty of
experience directing personal yet epic
stories that spend years and continents
it seems only appropriate that he would
be the right choice for the Goldfinch a
film which makes its way across the
world while still remaining
introspective and personal in 2017
Warner Brothers announced that it was
teaming up with Amazon Studios to
partner on the Goldfinch
meeting Amazon would invest a
significant chunk of the film's budget
reportedly totaling close to 40 million
dollars according to Variety in exchange
for streaming rights on their prime
service after the film's theatrical
release though many Studios aggressively
lobbied to be a part of this partnership
Amazon won out and that may be due to
more than their sizeable financial
contribution thanks to Manchester by the
sea and Amazon Studios produced in D
that scooped up multiple Academy Awards
the streaming service became the first
to score an Oscar nomination for Best
Picture which could only potentially
bode well for the goldfinches future
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]